Freunde heute schauen wir mal wieder bei
einem alten Freund vorbei bei Steffen
hensser ihr wisst vielleicht noch vor
einiger Zeit habe ich sein Restaurant
hier in Köln getestet dass ahoi nicht
sein top notch Restaurant also eher so
ein Restaurant was gehobene Mittelklasse
ist heute will ich mal gucken was da
mittlerweile so abgeht hat sich das Menü
geändert gibt es neue Speisen ich habe
auf jeden Fall jede Menge Hunger deshalb
werde ich mir alles bestellen was mir
gefällt schauen wir mal gemeinsam in die
Karte wir sind hier bei ahoi bei Steffen
Henssler viereinhalb Sterne aus 91
Bewertung nicht super viele Bewertungen
komischerweise aber was soll's Essen 5
Lieferung 5 Essen 4 Lieferung 2 Essen
war zum vereinbarten Zeitpunkt nicht
fertig 33 essen mag gut schmecken wenn
man vor Ort ist aber bis es zu Hause
ankam waren Pommes und Burger kalt zum
meist gute Bewertungen Lieferung
teilweise ein bisschen schlecht bewertet
aber okay gucken wir mal was es zu essen
gibt beliebt sind der crunchy
Chickenburger und die Chicken Teriyaki
Bowl gar nicht so wie man es denkt so
dieses maritime essen sondern schicken
weil Stefan ist ja eigentlich bekannt
für maritimes essen als Hamburger Jung
deshalb gucken wir auch eher in die
Richtung würde ich sagen Sushi bowls das
ist interessant beim letzten Mal hatte
ich glaube ich einen Thunfisch Burger
und Eric hatte heißt es nicht mehr genau
aber auf jeden Fall mir keine Sushi Ball
und Steffen Henssler ist ja vor allem
bekannt für sein Sushi deshalb würde ich
sagen nehmen wir eine Bowl und zwar die
prispy shrimp Bowl mit knusprig
gebackenen Garnelen und Steffens
Teriyaki Soße ab in den Warenkorb 16,90
€ ist generell habe ich ja letztes mal
schon festgestellt halt einfach so obere
Mittelklasse das Restaurant auf jeden
Fall schon eigentlich eher nichts für
jeden Tag Burger Teriyaki beef Burger
crunchy Chickenburger Veggie Burger
Tuner Burger den hatte ich beim letzten
Mal und krispy fish Burger ja ich würde
sagen wir probieren mal den crispy
Fischburger weil wenn wir ehrlich sind
ist das eigentlich ein Fischbrötchen
31,80 € zwei Artikel Steaks nee Deck
mache ich nicht ich bin Steak verstellen
ist wirklich so das Dümmste was man
machen kann also liefern lassen Classics
Currywurst und knuspriges Schnitzel vom
Landschwein 12,90 die Currywurst das ist
schon eher günstiger bei anderen
Restaurants nehmen wir die Currywurst
44,70 also nicht günstig heute ich werde
noch gleich paar Jungs bescheid sagen
dass wir das gemeinsam essen Chips muss
man eigentlich bestellen weil das gibt's
hier in Köln zumindest kaum also wenn
ich hier mal bestelle und das ein
bisschen weiter weg dann bestell ich das
jetzt auch und zwar Deluxe Style mit
Trüffel ponso Butter und Fritten nach
Henssler sein ein bisher nehmen wir noch
mitkommen lauwarmes für 850 irgendwie
wissen was das lauwarm ist immer mit
damit sind wir bei 69 € 70 ihr seht ihr
die Auflistung das ist ordentlich fünf
Speisen 70 €, ich würde sagen wir
schicken die Bestellung raus und hoffen
dass es zumindest annähernd so gut ist
wie beim letzten mal auch wenn es
geliefert wird schauen wir uns unsere
erste Speiser an wir haben hier eine
Bowl und ich muss sagen das ist wirklich
wirklich bunt und farbenfroht sieht auch
es sieht wirklich high quality aus also
das haben sie wirklich drauf auch Take
Away sieht richtig richtig klasse aus
knappe finde aber auch zum Beispiel
diese Avocado die so in irgendwelchen
momentan mit ein bisschen Sesam ist und
so wir sind einfach Sachen die nicht
Standard sind und dafür liebe ich das
wenn man mehr bezahlt dann sollte es
auch nicht Standard sein so gucken wir
mal die Mango hast du nämlich wenn Mango
noch hart ist sie ist schon weich crispy
schwimmt ist crispy shrimp crispy boah
crispyrimp ist crispy crispyrim ist geil
also das frittierte schmeckt wirklich
brutal der Sushi Reis ist schön klebrig
hat oben drüber so eine kleine Überzug
aus Sojasauce
richtig richtig richtig klebrig erreicht
so wie er sein soll süß salzig auf
einmal wirklich eine Geschmacksexplosion
diese Avocado ich kann es gerade nicht
wirklich verstehen komm ich seit dem
Video nicht noch mal Tage gegessen habe
manchmal ist das so mein Bild von einem
Laden gehen man nimmt sich vor da gehe
ich jetzt häufiger hin und dann macht
man es nicht
ärger mich gerade sehr darüber weil das
ist wirklich wirklich lecker
geschmacklich eine neuen von zehn
richtig gut weiter geht's mit der
nächsten Speise gucken wir was uns
erwartet Fisch and Chips bisschen unter
der Lieferung gelitten ich wette der war
mal richtig knusprig und ich Fischen
Chips irgendwie sondern Fischen Chips
Deluxe und warum ist es Deluxe wegen
diesem Paket was ich hier drunter
verbirgt welches geschmolzen ist alter
das ist durch den heißen Fisch schmolzen
das lässt sich jetzt auch nicht mehr so
gut öffnen das kann man auf jeden Fall
optimieren würde ich sagen an der Stelle
Butter boah Finger linking good ich
mache mir direkt mal hier so ein
bisschen Zitrone darüber auch dass sie
so groß und lang sind diese
Seelachsfilet Streifen geil hier rein in
diese Trüffel ponso Butter
trotz Lieferung ich habe wirklich
vergessen wie geil das ist auch die
Pommes mit dieser Art Essen kriegt man
hier in Köln einfach nicht falls Sie
jetzt aus dem Norden Deutschlands
zuschaut am besten aus Hamburg oder so
denke ich Digger was ist daran besonders
für mich ist das besonders ich bin hier
in Köln ihr kriegt man so so geiles
maritimes Essen nicht dazu muss ich
sagen ich bin mir fast sicher dass es
noch besser ist im Restaurant also das
liefern zu lassen ist nicht die erste
Wahl aber manchmal wenn man halt ein
bisschen entspannen weiter geht's mit
dem nächsten Gericht das dürfte
wahrscheinlich der Burger sein und es
ist auch der Burger ah okay das war
nicht so schlau da ist der gleiche
Backfisch drauf und die gleichen Pommes
dabei deshalb schnell Durchlauf Pommes
und verändert gut ich weiß noch bei
meinem Test gemeinsam mit Eric übrigens
sondern erik ist gerade im Urlaub
deshalb ist premier hinter der Kamera
hallo ähm ich liebe dich noch habe ich
auch gesagt dass das wirklich gute
Pommes sind die sind so doppelt
frittiert vielleicht auch dreifach
frittiert allein dass sie jetzt noch
diesen Crunch haben
schnell mal in den seafood Burger rein
wir sehen schon mal das Band ist so
schön gelblich so ein bisschen das
brioch vielleicht ist da so ein bisschen
Hartweizengries drin oder deshalb ist
das Geld probieren wir sind die Soßen
das muss man wirklich sagen Steffen
Henssler der Mann weiß schon einiges
über Essen und das merkt man auch in
seinem Restaurants eine warme Speise
haben wir noch und dann kommt natürlich
das Dessert hier drin das ist schwer das
ist wirklich schwer haben wir
habe schon fast vergessen die Currywurst
jetzt bin ich wirklich gespannt wer bei
allem was bisher kam habe ich nicht so
gute Vergleichs
Werte gucken wir ob der Hamburger Jung
auch Ahnung von Currywurst hat ich bin
sehr gespannt ob die was taugt
vielleicht ist ein bisschen scharf die
Pommes wir werden sie wohl schmecken
rein in die Wurst
angespitzt geschnitten ich probiere
einfach Digger
man schmeckt dass das nicht so eine
Standard billo Bratwurst ist aber 13 €
ist schon für so eine Currywurst die
halt wirklich sowas was ehrliches es ist
so dass man sich auch mal auf dem
Bauhaus Parkplatz holen kann ist das
schon ordentlich ist aber auch im
Prinzip der Fehler von den Leuten die
sich da eine Currywurst bestellen weil
man geht da nicht für Currywurst hin man
holt sich da diese geilen fischsachen
und so wenn sie übelst gut ja aber es
ist auch nicht die beste Currywurst
meines Lebens ich würde ihr
siebeneinhalb von zehn geben Leute ich
brauche eine kleine Abkühlung und das
hier ist unser lauwarmes
Schokotörtchen das stand zwar nicht bei
der Bestellliste aber unser Eis ist auch
noch halbwegs im Takt ich meine das ist
ein heißes Schokotörtchen und das fast
geschmolzene Eis aber das brauche ich
jetzt geil aber ob es ein besonderes Eis
ist keine Ahnung dazu rote Grütze
und der große Punkt ist es flüssig hat
es ein lauwarm Kern oh das sieht schon
aus wie so Nutella in der Mitte jo guckt
euch das an da macht man halt wirklich
nie irgendwas falsch ne solche Törtchen
gibt's halt auch häufig ne wenn man kann
die mittlerweile sogar auch als
Gastronomie irgendwie vorgefertigt
kaufen ich weiß nicht ob das frisch
gemacht ist lecker es ist aber alle Male
das von Steffen Henssler ist einfach ein
richtig gutes Restaurant es ist wirklich
schade für mich dass das soweit
außerhalb ist sonst würde ich da
häufiger mal vorbei gehen zum Bestellen
ist es eigentlich ein bisschen zu teuer
so um sich da hinzusetzen ins schöne
Restaurant und den Service zu genießen
safe 100% fair zum Bestellen vielleicht
ein bisschen zu viel aber
nichtsdestotrotz sobald man das Essen
genießt bereut man es auf jeden Fall
nicht deshalb Probst am Steffen Henssler
schreib endlich mal zurück wann ich für
die kochen darf und bis zum nächsten Mal
ciao
[Musik]